no matter how you look at it it's got to
be a major bummer to be unceremoniously
cut from one of the biggest films of all
time late last year it was announced
that 13 reasons why star Catherine
Langford had been cast in the small but
important role in Avengers in game but
the talented actress was nowhere to be
found in the final cut of the film that
is shocking I'm shocked
and now we know all the reasons why
warning you're about to hear some major
spoilers for Avengers in games starting
right this minute if you've already seen
the film you know all too well that Tony
Stark makes the ultimate sacrifice while
reducing vanos and his minions to so
much dust and wind as heart-wrenching as
the moment is it's also the perfect
conclusion to starts character arc
during in games five-year time jump we
learned that he's retreated from the
public eye and had a daughter named
Morgan start with the love of his life
Pepper Potts realizing that he has a
responsibility both to the universe and
to his own beloved family Stark
heroically offers up his own life so
that the mad Titan can be defeated once
and for all
during a recent appearance on MTV's
happy sad confused podcast co directors
Joe and Anthony Russo revealed that
Catherine Langford had been cast as an
older version of Morgan she was supposed
to appear to Stark in the same
netherworld where Thanos finds young
Gamora in Avengers infinity war does
this plot development sound confusing to
you if so the directors wholeheartedly
agree and that's why Langford seemed
ultimately wound up on the cutting room
floor as co-director Joe Russo explained
the intention was that his future
daughter would gave him and sort of gave
him peace to go and the idea felt
resonant but it was just too many ideas
in an overly complicated movie even
though the audience got to see the
emotional bond between stark and young
Morgan the directors realized that the
sudden appearance of an older version of
Morgan wouldn't really register with
audiences co-director Anthony Russo
admitted it wasn't ringing to us and
resonating with us on an emotional level
even though Langford isn't featured in
the final cut of Avengers endgame there
may be a silver lining to the
unfortunate situation obviously her
acting chops impressed Marvel Studios
enough for them to cast her in the role
with that in mind it's entirely possible
that Morgan Stark may return to the MCU
in a future film although nothing has
been announced yet since in game's
release a lot of people have speculated
that the film is
the appearance of the Young Avengers a
superhero team that's been featured in
the pages of Marvel Comics since 2005
while the emcee used version of The
Young Avengers would probably differ
from the comics we're sure a few key
players would ultimately make the leap
from the page to the screen chief among
these Cassie Lang the daughter of
ant-man in the comic books she becomes
the crime fighter known as stature and
then there's Clint Barton starter Lila
who some viewers think might eventually
take over as Hawkeye
there's also Harley keener Starks young
buddy from Iron Man 3 who popped up it
starts funeral in Avengers in game if
the Young Avengers are going to figure
prominently in Marvel's phase 4 why not
tap the daughter of Iron Man to leave
them here's hoping Lankford was cast an
in-game with an eye towards the future
with any luck the actress will receive a
consolation prize for her abandoned
cameo and score a major recurring role
in history's biggest ever film franchise
otherwise yeah that is a serious bummer
for Lankford and for us check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more exclusive looper videos about the
Marvel Cinematic Universe are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]